okay let's talk about Anthony Kennedy
the retirement of Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy is very quickly becoming
really concerning and this is a crazy
question that we have to ask but we have
to ask whether Anthony Kennedy was
forced induced or pressured to resign
because of financial dealings between
his son Justin Kennedy and Donald
Trump's businesses and if this is the
first year hearing of this I know when I
first heard about this I thought no way
there there's not even anything to look
into here but then we learned that
actually it did come as a surprise to
the other Supreme Court justices that
Anthony Kennedy would be retiring which
is unusual usually the retiring justice
let's the other justices know ahead of
time so that was strange
and then we learned about the very
suspect relationship between Donald
Trump and Justice Anthony Kennedy 'he's
son and the first inkling of this
actually came when Donald Trump gave his
first speech to Congress in February of
2017 that first one after being
inaugurated not typically called the
State of the Union but it's effectively
what it was and we have audio and video
and in the video you're gonna see Donald
Trump talking to Justice Anthony Kennedy
about his son
talking about what a special guy Anthony
Kennedy's son is and Anthony Kennedy
does look somewhat uncomfortable during
the clip to put it lightly let's take a
listen
so wait a second what how does Trump
know Anthony Kennedy's son Justin
Kennedy well it turns out that Justin
Kennedy worked for Deutsche Bank for
more than a decade already interesting
since robert muller is looking
extensively at deutsche bank as part of
the russia investigation because at one
point deutsche bank was one of the only
banks willing to lend to donald trump
and then we learned well it's not just
that Justin Kennedy was working at
Deutsche Bank when Trump was getting
loans from Deutsche Bank he was actually
working directly on Trump projects and
Justin Kennedy is responsible for more
than 1 billion dollars in loans for real
estate projects once again when other
banks were opting not to work with Trump
so ok that gets a little stranger now in
combination with the seemingly
unexpected resignation of Anthony
Kennedy now I know that the
right-wingers will hear me say that and
they'll write in and they'll say David
guys almost 82 years old Anthony Kennedy
it's not a surprise to anyone that he's
retiring that's not the point the point
is that the other justices were
reportedly surprised about the
retirement and that's not common no
matter how old Anthony Kennedy is so
let's review we've got the surprising
sort of haphazard retirement
announcement by Anthony Kennedy we have
the fact that Justin Kennedy loaned
Trump money when other banks were
turning away from Donald Trump and then
we also do have a year and a half of
Supreme Court decisions where Anthony
Kennedy typically known as the sort of
swing vote moderate vote sometimes the
fifth vote out of nine against an
administration voting frequently as the
fifth vote for Donald Trump's
administration at the Supreme Court so
we've got the swing vote who has been
helping the Trump administration
frequently since 2017 whose son happens
to be the one guy lending more than a
billion dollars to Donald Trump while
working at a bank that was fine six
hundred and thirty million dollars for a
ten billion dollar Russian
money-laundering scam in 2017 which has
all red
come to the attention of special
prosecutor Robert molar that's a lot of
coincidences and Richard painter who is
the Bush administration ethics lawyer
believes that it stinks and he tweeted
over the weekend the circumstances of
Justice Kennedy's resignation must be
investigated by the Senate Judiciary
Committee before any replacement is
considered the Constitution does not
give Trump the power to use underhanded
means to induce Supreme Court
resignations I want to give Politico
praise why Politico because Politico
caught this relationship more than a
year ago and I missed it and many other
people missed it they had an article
more than a year ago in April of 2017
called Trump's hidden back channel to
Justice Kennedy their kids they were on
it and a lot of people missed it now
there's one other possibility and I want
to I'll be upfront this is all very
circumstantial there's another
possibility which is that Anthony
Kennedy decided to retire because he's
perfectly happy to leave his legacy and
the future of the Supreme Court for a
generation in the hands of Donald Trump
that's almost worse that's actually
almost worse than something sketchy
coercing him into retirement and thus we
are back to why Donald Trump will likely
not face consequences for any of what he
and his cronies have done because unless
the House and Senate acts much of what
Trump has done will or would be
hypothetically be adjudicated by the
Supreme Court a Supreme Court which is
increasingly in the control of Donald
Trump the guy being investigated selects
the judges who will determine his fate
at this point I don't know that we can
count on any actual resolution to much
of what we have seen the Trump
administration do during the campaign
before it was an administration and
since being inaugurated send me your
thoughts I want to know what you think
about this is this something that we
could even do anything about
I am unfortunately I think I'm just
depressed about the reality of the
situation discuss this with us on our
subreddit david pakman.com slash re d di
t quick break back after this today's
program is sponsored in part by
vitur which is a social forecasting game
for your phone or web browsers that
allows players to come together and
compete with each other to predict
future events who tor is built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market which is a scientifically
validated way of leveraging the wisdom
of the crowd to better estimate the
likelihood of future events and there
are a ton of different topics including
politics and here's how it works you go
on the app find a future event that you
feel confident enough about to make a
prediction and make a bet on the outcome
you think is most likely to happen using
the apps in game fake currency your
prediction is right you're rewarded with
more points and you compete with others
who are making their own predictions to
see who's the best forecaster there's no
real money or cryptocurrency involved
and that's kind of the fun of it the
whole point is use this social network
to prove how good you are at predicting
the future I have an account on the
futur app and I make predictions and you
can place your bets based on my
predictions as well go to futur com to
sign up and start making forecasts it's
totally free and it's available on both
Android and iOS and on web browsers and
right now on foote or you can win cash
prizes for correct predictions about the
World Cup check it out at fut you you
are calm